يقال ان بطولتين من كاس العالم سقط ثامن
تاريخ الكره بسبب الحرب العالميه روايات
اخرى تقول انهما اقيمت بالفعل وهناك من
توج باللقب لكن من دون كاس ذهبيه فالكاس
تم اخفائها فهل هناك فعلا مونديلاني
منسيان ام لا
كما تعلمون فان بطوله كاس العالم تنظم كل
اربع سنوات منذ تاسيسها عام 30 لكن في عام
42 حدث جدل حول من ينظم البطوله ففي
البدايه اسندت الفيفا تنظيم هذه البطوله
الى المانيا
والارجنتين بسبب استحواذ دول اوروبا على
تنظيم المونديال لدورتين متتاليتين
الاوروغواي نظمت اول بطوله على 30 ثم
استضافت ايطاليا بطوله عام 34 ثم فرنسا
عام 38 وفي عام 42 كان من المفترض ان يذهب
التنظيم لامريكا الجنوبيه لكن الفيفا لم
يتخذ القرار النهائيه بسبب احداث الحرب
العالميه الثانيه فاا الغيت هذه البطوله
لكن بعض المؤرخين قالوا ان مونديال عام 42
اقيم في الارجنتين بالفعل
كان هناك مونديال الرسمي عام
1942 اقيم في الارجنتين ضمه 12 فريقا
مكونه من لاعبين محترفين ومهاجرين من كل
انحاء العالم لكن لم يعرف حتى الان الفريق
الذي توج بالبطوله حينها الا ان هناك
روايه اخرى تحدثت عن اقامه مباراه في
المانيا جماعه المانيا ضد السويد ضد
نهائيا غير رسمي لكاس العالم امام ما يقرب
من 100,000 مشجع فازت السويد باللقاء لكن
لم يتم تسليمها اي كاس الرسميه بعدها
بثلاث سنوات انتهت الحرب العالميه الثانيه
وتحديدا في عام 45 وبدات الانظار تتجه نحو
تنظيم مونديال عام 46 عام واحد لم يكن
كافيا لتنظيم بطوله بحجم كاس العالم لكن
كانت هناك بطوله موازيه تقام في ذلك الوقت
وهي بطوله امريكا الجنوبيه نهائيا جمع
الارجنتين والبرازيل فاز التانجو على
السامبا بهد هيني مقابل لا شيء وتوجت
الارجنتين باللقب
فيفا لم تعترف بهذا اللقب لكن الكثير من
الامريكيين الجنوبيين اعتبروا ان هذا
اللقب هو لقب كاس العالم غير الرسمي مهلا
هناك سؤال شغل فكر الكثيرين حينها وهو اين
اختفت الكاس الذهبيه في تلك الفتره طلب
هتلر استضافه المانيا لمونديال عام 42 كلف
ضباطه بالبحث عن الكاس في ايطاليا لجلبها
الى بلاده من اجل تنظيم هذه البطوله في
المقابل الاتحاد الايطالي حينها خاف من
ضياع كاس العالم او سرقتها لذلك وضعها
كوديعها في احد دونك روما لكن نائب رئيس
الفيفا حينها براسي كان له راي اخر فقد
ذهب الى البنك واخذ الكاس سرا دون ان يعلم
احد وظل محتفظ بها طوال هذه السنوات في
صندوق احذيته تحت سرير نومه